[Music]
as we're beginning to see statistics
sharpens our knowledge of how randomness
is all around us life is full of having
to make decisions under uncertainty in
fact the two fundamental ideas of
statistics are uncertainty and variation
now in some cases the uncertainty is
because the outcome in question hasn't
been determined yet
like who win the next Super Bowl my
money's on the Atlanta Falcons cuz I'm
from Georgia but in other cases the
uncertainty is because although the
outcome has been determined already
we're not aware of it like whether or
not our application for a car loan has
been approved a probability is the
foundation that helps us understand
uncertainty and variation and that's why
probability plays a key role in
statistics by definition probability is
a mathematical language that we use to
measure uncertain events now whenever we
collect data or make measurements the
process that we use is subject to
variation meaning if the same
measurements were repeated the answer
would be slightly different due to
variation so what is this data that
we're collecting anyway well one way to
think of it is data is the raw
information from which statistics are
created data's being collected
everywhere all the time and when we
collect data what we're doing is really
converting information into numbers but
what do we do with those numbers
well statistical thinking gives you the
tools to intelligently extract
information from data it's helpful to
think about data collection in the
context of the general process of
investigation step 1
we state the question that we're
interested in so maybe we want to know
whether drinking caffeinated beverages
affects men differently than women or if
a new cold medicine will relieve
coughing within 48 hours whatever the
question is we need to be able to gather
information that'll help us make a
decision and that's step to collect data
that helps answer the question okay back
to our cold medicine example suppose I
give some samples of cold medicine to my
coughing friends and you give some to
your coughing friends and we record how
many of them stop coughing within the 48
hour period we've collected data now
what well do you think we're ready to
move on
not quite you see what we've just
introduced is a bias and we put that
into our data it's likely that our close
friends have similar characteristics as
we do maybe they're in our same age
bracket or they live in the same city in
my case most of them are women so in
order for our results to be widely
applicable we have to collect data in a
way that's objective and rigorous one
improvement we could stand in front of a
drugstore and sample people as they go
in and out another perhaps might be to
call random numbers from a phone book
and ask people to participate in our
trial but both of these methods are
still biased if we're sampling only from
a particular group then our results will
only apply to that group if we want to
remove bias entirely we have to collect
a sample where every person has an equal
chance of being selected now once we've
stated the question and collected
appropriate data we can move to step
three which is analyze the data this is
where we really begin to see the ideas
of probability and statistics take shape
literally statisticians often start an
analysis with a graphical look at the
data to get an overall picture of it we
use plots graphs tables anything that
can help us reveal patterns or
relationships within our data
now a plot or a graph can be a more
effective way of presenting data than
just a massive numbers because we can
see where the data is clustered and
where there's only a few data values
then we could also use formal techniques
like hypothesis testing or linear
regression to determine if or how much
our data supports our initial claim
ultimately we want to use our analysis
to make a decision about our problem
statement which leads us to step four in
the last step we draw a conclusion here
we consider all the information that
we've gathered and we analyzed and we
make a definitive statement about our
problem something like study shows that
numerical cough medicine relieves
coughing in 48 hours guaranteed how's
that sound
all right well that conclusion is too
strong in fact a conclusion with zero
uncertainty is really too good to be
true but we do want to extend the
results from our sample data the data
that we collected to the overall
population more generally this lesson is
going to give you a strong foundation in
probablistic reasoning and the basic
tools needed to make sense of it all we
first start with sampling which refers
to selecting at random one or more of
all possible outcomes so for example
selecting a random sample of Americans
for a political poll or maybe even
drawing a hand of 5 cards out of a deck
of 52 or finding 10 pennies on the
sidewalk and recording their ages
sampling helps us draw inference about
the larger population of outcomes now
drawing random samples forms the
foundation of probability which is all
about considering the possible outcomes
and enix of an experiment and
quantifying their chances how many of us
have ever heard a weather forecaster
declare there's a 75 percent chance of
rain today well what this really means
is that in a large number of days with
atmospheric conditions like those today
the proportion
days in which rain occurs is 75% so why
then does probability refer to the
long-run well it's simply because we
can't accurately determine a probability
with a small number of observations if I
sample 10 people and they're all
right-handed I can't conclude that
probability of being right-handed is a
hundred percent it takes a much larger
sample of people to accurately predict
the proportion of people that are truly
right-handed so what happens when we
have real but limited data and we want
to make a conclusion from it maybe
calculate some probabilities we don't
have time to go in the long run so what
do we do with this limited sample size
or here's an example in that case
suppose we wanted to understand how a
grocery store displays their cereal
boxes and whether different types of
cereals are targeted to adults or
children we go into a grocery store and
we notice that there are six rows of
shelves and each shelf has five boxes of
cereal we can group the six shelves into
three categories the bottom two shelves
the middle two shelves and the top two
shelves here's a look at that data now
notice in the first column we have
adults children and the total the second
column tells us how many boxes of cereal
are located on the top two shelves so
nine boxes are targeted at adults one
for children for a total of ten boxes
likewise in the middle two shelves three
boxes of cereals are targeted at adults
seven for children and a total of ten
and then you see the bottom two no boxes
targeted at adults 10 for children out
of a total of ten the far most right
column total is going to add up the
total number of boxes that are targeted
at adults which is twelve and targeted
at children which is 18 suppose we
wanted to know the probability that
breakfast cereal is targeted at adults
let's call this event a well the
probability of a would be 12
which is the total number targeted at
adults out of 30 which is the total
number of cereal boxes or 40% now we can
do the same type of calculation and
determine the probability of breakfast
cereal being in the middle two rows for
instance let's call that B the
probability of B would be 10 out of 30
or 0.33 now is natural to think about
how to events relate to each other for
example what's the probability that the
cereal is targeted at adults and located
on the middle two shelves now in this
case we want to look at our data to see
where those two events occur together
notice that three types of breakfast
cereals are located in the middle two
shelves and targeted at adults so our
probability would be 3 over 30 now we
use this upside down U to refer to the
intersection or the place where two
events overlap so the probability of a
intersect B is equal to 10 percent or
0.1 now what if we were interested in
knowing the probability of A or B
probability that cereal is targeted at
adults or is located on the middle two
shelves in this case we're no longer
limited to just the intersection the
cereal could be targeted at adults with
probability 12 over 30 or Atari are
located on the middle two shelves with
probability 10 over 30 so it makes sense
for us to add these two probabilities
the probability of a union B equals 12
over 30 plus 10 over 30 but do you see a
problem here notice that by adding the
probability of a plus the probability of
B we've included their intersection
twice we need to subtract one of those
back out so the probability of a union B
is equal to the probability of a plus
the probability of B minus the
probability of their intersection so 12
over 30 plus 10 over 30 minus 3 over 30
to give us Oh point 6 3 or 19 over 30
now if you've ever visited beautiful
sunny Southern California you'll have
noticed that there's one thing that we
have very little of and it's rain in
fact and this is a true story that my
husband probably wouldn't want me to
share with you I remember once when the
windshield wipers on our car
malfunctioned and they stopped working
completely and we went seven months
without getting them fixed simply
because there was no rain event
significant for us to need to use them
I'm sure that'll stay between the two of
us but now suppose one morning I walk
outside and I see dark clouds in the sky
well all of a sudden the probability of
rain at least to me has now increased
what I've just done is updated my belief
about rain
having seen dark clouds in the sky
likewise we could update our probability
of events by conditioning on new given
information let's go back to our serial
example and define a new event let's see
B the event that serial is targeted to
children what's the probability of C
well that's 18 out of 30 or 60 percent
so there's a 60% chance that cereal is
targeted toward children what's the
probability of C and B or remember B is
the event that cereal is located on the
middle two shelves well here again we're
looking at the overlap or the
intersection of these two events so the
probability of C intersect B is 7 out of
30 or 0.23 now what is the probability
that cereal is targeted to children
given that is located on the middle two
shelves this question is asking what's
the probability of event C given the
information from a bin event B so now we
write the probability of C given B which
is what that slash represents which is 7
out of 10 or 70% we've limited ourselves
to the middle two shelves and of those
10 boxes of cereal we see that 7 of them
are
targeted to children so our conditional
probability was actually higher let's
add some formal definitions to what we
just learned in that example first an
experiment this is an action whose
outcome is uncertain examples might be
flipping a fair coin or rolling a fair
die twice from experiments we can build
a sample space this is a set of all
possible outcomes of that experiment in
our flipping a coin example our sample
space s would be equal to either H for
heads or T for tails
likewise if we're rolling a fair die
twice our sample space for all possible
combinations of those two rolls so we
might roll one and one one and two all
the way up to six five and six six and
everything in between we define an event
as a collection of outcomes of our
experiment if we flip a fair coin for
example the event might be that we flip
a head or in our rolling a fair die
maybe we define an event as the sum
equals four in which case there are
three possibilities one in three two and
two or three and one so from these
events we want to associate a
probability to them a probability is
just a rule that assigns each event a
value on the interval from zero to one
that's going to reflect the chance of
that event occurring now when all the
outcomes in the sample space are equally
likely the probability of event is just
the number of outcomes corresponding to
that event
divided by the total number of outcomes
let's go back to flipping a fair coin
what's the probability that we flip a
head we probably know that's one half
but we get that by taking the number of
events and flipping a head which is H or
one event out of the total number of
possible events which is two likewise if
we roll a fair die twice the probability
that the sum equals 4 equals those three
events out of the total 36 possibilities
so 3 over 36
now the building blocks of Statistics
are what we call the axioms of
probability these are the beginning
statements that are the ground rules
from which we build and prove
statistical theory we can reduce
probability theory to just three
fundamental axioms let's talk about them
now the first one is this for any event
a the probability of a is between 0 and
1 the small is a probability can be a 0
so we can't have any negative values
associated with probability like Y is
the largest it can be as 1 the second
axiom tells us this if s is a sample
space the probability of the sample
space is equal to 1 also the empty set
which is everything that is not in the
sample space is equal to 0 so the
probability of our empty set or no event
is equal to 0 the sample space is
everything possible for our experiment
and there are no events that live
outside of that space now the third
axiom of probability deals with mutually
exclusive events but first we need to
understand unions and intersections
formally a union the probability of A or
B is denoted by probability of a union B
or a you sign likewise the intersection
is the probability of both a and B and
we did note that as P of a intersect B
or an upside-down u now if a and B are
mutually exclusive meaning they don't
overlap or they don't intersect with
each other
then if we wanted to get the probability
of their union it's just the sum of
those probabilities so P if a union B is
equal to P of a plus P of B now what
about the probability of a not happening
we actually have a word for this a
complement it's the probability of a
complement is 1 minus the probability of
a more formally if we're looking at the
probability of a union of events we saw
in our example that the probability of a
union B equals the probability of a
plus the probability of B minus the
probability of their intersection now if
they're mutually exclusive the
intersection has probability 0 which
leads us to the last one if a and B are
independent the probability of their
union is the product of their two
probabilities now this leads us to the
idea of conditional probability knowing
that the serial is located on the middle
two shelves now changes the probability
of being targeted to children more
formally let's let a and B be events
where probability of B has positive
probability then the conditional
probability of a given that B has
occurred is defined as the following P
of a given B is equal to the probability
of a intersected with B divided by the
probability of B now if we go back to
our example we could actually calculate
the probability of C given B now using
our formal definition another way to
view conditional probability is by
solving for the intersection term we can
rewrite our definition as follows
the probability of a intersect B is
equal to the conditional probability of
a given B times the probability of B all
right so now the probability of a and B
occurring well that's the same as a
probability of B and a occurring so we
could write that slightly differently
probability of a intersect B is P of B
given a times P of a we can set these
two equations equal to each other to get
P of a given B times P of B equals P of
B given a times P of a alright now at
first sight it might not seem very
useful in fact it seems pretty circular
that we've just rewritten the
probability of a and B and probability
of B and a and set them equal to each
other but if you divide both sides by
the probability of B what you're left
with is an extremely famous extremely
useful result that relates conditional
probabilities and it's known as Bayes
rule Bayes rule simply states that the
probability of a given B equals the
probability of B given a times P of a
divided by P of B let's take that
denominator and in fact we can expand it
usually what we call the law of total
probability we can write out the
probability of B as the probability of B
intersected with a plus the probability
of B intersected with a complement
we showed where that intersection could
be written as a conditional probability
so we can further dissect that into the
probability of B given a times P of a
plus the probability of B given a
complement times the probability of a
complement put that on your denominator
and you'll see another form of Bayes
rule where we can write the conditional
probability of a given B as P of B given
a times P of a all over the sum of P of
B given a times P of A plus P of B given
a complement times P of a complement now
Bayes rule is a powerful tool that we
can use and it can actually help you in
everyday life suppose you're worried
that you might have a rare disease you
visit your doctor and get tested and she
tells you the test is accurate 98% of
the time so if you have the rare disease
it'll correctly tell you that you have
it 98 percent of the time
likewise if you don't have the disease
it'll correctly tell you that you don't
have it 98 percent of the time now this
disease is rare and it's deadly and it
occurs and only one of every 10,000
people unfortunately your test result is
positive but what's the chance that you
actually have the disease some people
guess this probability is around 98% but
Bayes theorem is going to help us answer
this question let's define an event
a where we have the disease and the
event B that the test is positive we
want to know what's the probability of a
given B what's the probability that I
have the disease given that my test is
positive well I don't know that but I
can use Bayes rule to solve for it first
let's write out what we do know the
probability of B given a probability
that the test is positive given that we
have the disease is 0.98 or 98% likewise
the probability of the disease is one in
10,000 or point zero zero zero one the
probability of B given a compliment that
the test is positive given that we don't
have the disease it's point o2 and the
probability of not having the disease or
a compliment is one minus P of a or
0.9999
so from here we can plug this into Bayes
rule to get the probability of us having
the disease given that we got a positive
test result let's do that now notice in
the numerator we've substituted in the
conditional probability of B given a
which is 0.98 times the probability of a
0.0001 and in the denominator we've used
the law of total probability to write
out the probability of B given a times P
of a plus probability of B given a
complement times the probability of a
complement when you plug all this in do
the math notice that you get point zero
zero four eight seven six six so your
test is positive and the test is
accurate 98% of the time but the chance
that you have the disease it's actually
less than one percent well I hope you
see how you can use amazing techniques
like Bayes rule even in your everyday
life maybe even the next time you're
with your doctor and you get a positive
test result you can sit down with them
pull out Bayes rule and calculate the
probability that you act
we have the disease